[Música]
gracias por seguir con nosotros en
france 24 bienvenidos a en 5 minutos con
nos acompaña marcos espinal el director
del departamento de enfermedades
transmisibles de la organización
panamericana de la salud la opc doctor
muchas gracias por esta comunicación las
estrategias de aislamiento y seguimiento
que se han aplicado en los países han
sido exitosas muchas gracias y las
estrategias son exitosas lo que pasa es
que no podemos tampoco pedir
perfeccionismo porque es un virus nuevo
es un virus que no tenemos un año
calendario pero hemos visto como países
ya como chile han pasado el pico y la
curva se mantiene baja vamos a seguir
teniendo casos porque hay diferentes
cambios de temperatura pero lo
importante es mantener ese virus en los
casos al mínimo y lo más importante
prevenir las enfermedades las medidas no
farmacéuticas son muy importantes el
distanciamiento el aislamiento de los
contactos de los casos positivos y el
uso de la mascarilla y el lavado de mano
así que es muy importante mantener estas
medidas hay altas y bajas pero podemos
decir que son exitosas doctor porque hay
países que no han implementado
estrategias como la de tamizar
poblaciones asintomáticas la ope se ha
adornado prueba diagnóstica a casi todos
los países de la región de las américas
en latinoamérica y el caribe ha
capacitado todos los laboratorios
recordar que estos laboratorios se
adaptaron porque se utilizaron los
laboratorios que que hacen las pruebas
para influenza que es un sistema de
vigilancia muy avanzado y están
funcionando perfectamente lo de hacer
pruebas a todos los asintomáticos es un
poco complicado también porque
ha habido también
como dicen a falta de pruebas
hay también pruebas que no son las
mejores entonces hay que ser muy
cuidadoso con eso porque los falsos
positivos y los falsos negativos pueden
llevar a cosas no muy bien entonces lo
más importante la prioridad es aquel que
está experimentando síntomas de la
enfermedad recordar también que los el
80% de los casos son leves o moderados y
no necesitan hospitalización y se van a
curar solo es básicamente director
espinal cómo actuar a la ope s para que
la región tenga acceso a las vacunas
cuando estén disponibles la ope s ya ha
tomado muy proactivamente este tema y ha
negociado con la iniciativa kóvacs que
es la iniciativa con sede en ginebra en
la alianza gavi de vacunas que también
es parte de la o ms que ha negociado que
nuestros países de la región entren en
bloque
y más de 30 países casi 40 países yo
diría que han enviado sus cartas de
intención han llegado a acuerdos y
entonces las primeras dosis que lleguen
van a ser utilizadas para los
trabajadores de salud y las personas con
riesgos y condiciones como los mayores
de 60 años los que tienen enfermedades
cardiovasculares diabetes pero esta
experiencia que nos identifica pues se
va actualizando no doctor con la llegada
del cobi 19 que ha cambiado en el manejo
que la ope se le da a las enfermedades
transmisibles bueno hay dos cosas
importantes acá no descuidar o bajar la
guardia con respecto al como vi pero
tampoco la ope ciencia ha bajado la
guardia con respecto a otras
enfermedades
estamos realizando capacitaciones
virtuales estamos realizando
cooperación técnica con los ministerios
de salud virtualmente para que no olvide
que también no olviden que nuestros
países tienen también tuberculosis
tienen malaria tienen cánceres tienen
enfermedades cardiovasculares
es clave no bajan la guardia en estas
enfermedades porque recordar que la
región de las américas ha llegado muy
lejos en la en el control y eliminación
de otras enfermedades transmisibles pero
si descuidamos nuestra guardia estas
enfermedades van a volver a subir como
ha sucedido por ejemplo cuando subió la
malaria muy fuerte en venezuela entonces
es muy frágil todo así que la ope y se
mantiene esa vía doble vía de no
descuidar al kobe y no descuidar las
demás enfermedades y es el llamado que
le hacemos a los ministerios de salud
porque al fin y al cabo las poblaciones
también tienen derecho universal a la
salud y todos debemos tener acceso a la
salud de calidad bien pues marcos
espinal muchas gracias por esta la
comunicación el director del
departamento de enfermedades
transmisibles de la ope s gracias a
ustedes también siga con más en france
[Música]